this was all that was left of the right
engine of a boeing triple seven just
minutes after takeoff the blaze forced
united airlines flight 328
bound for honolulu to make an emergency
landing
leaving a trail of smoke behind 28
heavyweight spirits of failure need a
turn mayday made a united
28 9328 heavy mayday mayday
it was a nerve shredding few minutes for
those on board before the plane touched
down safely back to denver
with all the 231 passengers and 10 crew
unharmed but shaken by the experience
i could definitely see things flying at
me and
yeah my daughter was sitting on the
window and she's a you know i i was just
like don't
look like let's let's close it up and
let's just pray so that's what we did we
kind of just held hands and
said some prayers so it was shaky it was
a shaky ride all the way down
yeah you couldn't really see any fire at
first and there was smoke and then
a little later than the fire came along
but we were right there in that window
facing it those on the ground watched in
horror as the plane descended
shedding debris in its wake no it's
something
blew up this engine part
narrowly missed the roof of a home 20
miles from denver i thought the wind had
blown my neighbor's trampoline over
because i could just see the metal like
the tree was kind of blocking where i
was inside the house
but when i as soon as i opened the door
i go oh that's the front engine of a
plane
more plane parts rained down on
residential streets and football fields
but remarkably no one was injured
experts say that falling debris was the
biggest threat here
because the aircraft and crew are
equipped to deal with this kind of fault
i can think of several cases where this
has happened it is rare
but it's not unknown but each time the
aircraft has landed satisfactorily
with a with a one engine effectively
destroyed the national transportation
safety board will now investigate
exactly what caused the engine fire
and has asked for the debris not to be
moved for those on the plane
and on the ground this was a lucky
escape
milanda sky news